la tondeuse Chartres réalisée par
Patrick caboin un documentaire du même
nom que la célèbre photo prise par
Robert Capa lors de la libération de la
ville le 16 août 1944 ce film est cette
photo nous renvoie on l'a vu à une
période trouble de notre histoire celle
de l'épuration engagée un peu partout en
France pendant et juste après la
Libération une période qui aujourd'hui
encore soulèvent bon nombre de questions
auxquelles nous allons tenter maintenant
d'apporter quelques réponses avec mes
invités en commençant avec vous Fabrice
virgini bienvenue on vous a vu et
entendu dans ce documentaire et pour
cause vous êtes un spécialiste du sujet
qui nous concerne aujourd'hui avec entre
autres cet ouvrage que vous avez écrit
avec François Rouquet intitulé les
Françaises les Français et les plus
rations avec nous également Annie la
croix-rise bienvenue à vous aussi vous
êtes également historienne et vous venez
publié chez Armand Collin ce livre
intitulé La non-épuration en France de
1943 aux années 50 alors le titre est
très explicite et on va bien sûr en
reparler tout de suite dans ce débat
puis enfin avec nous à Gland bienvenue
vous êtes également historienne
spécialiste du 20e siècle et plus
particulièrement de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et vous avez publié là aussi
dans la collection Folio histoire
1937-1947 la guerre monde en d'automne
c'est un ouvrage collectif que vous avez
dirigé avec l'historien Robert Franck
lorsqu'on regarde ce qui a été écrit
pour
les néophytes on va dire de cette
période très vite on semble distinguer
deux grandes périodes les plus rations
dites sauvages d'épurations immédiates
l'épuration violente et puis dans un
second temps l'épuration légale voilà ce
que nous dit le documentaire que nous
avons vu sur cette période d'épuration
on va dire sauvage regardez s'il s'agit
d'un homme dans la plupart des cas il a
le droit à une balle sans autre forme de
procès certains subissent des tortures
sont battus à mort ou exécutés après une
parodie de justice
[Musique]
les vannes de la vengeance sont ouvertes
l'épuration sauvages commencent
aux femmes en réserve un autre
traitement et tout particulièrement à
celles qui sont soupçonnées de
collaboration horizontale
insultes coûts
[Musique]
exhibition publique pour les femmes
tombent évidemment c'est l'attendu de
Chartres exécution sommaire pour les
hommes c'est d'une violence inouïe cette
période de notre histoire alors la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et d'une
violence inouïe en effet et les plus
rations ne peut être comprise que dans
la seconde guerre mondiale elle commence
au moment de l'occupation et même dès le
tout début de l'occupation l'idée qu'il
faut s'en prendre qu'il faudra s'en
prendre à ceux qui trahissent devant nos
yeux quand je dis non c'est les
contemporains de l'époque évidemment et
que à ce moment-là ils auront à rendre
les comptes et on s'en prendra eux de
manière violente donc l'épuration bien
sûr est violente parce qu'elle est dans
ce grand moment de violence donc cette
vindique populaire cette soif de
vengeance que vous évoquiez elle vient
de loin elle vient peut-être de cette
période de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
vous l'avez dit peut-être même d'avant
certains disent de des 34 des 36 cette
période où la les nationalistes la
droite nationaliste est très forte dans
l'entre-deux-guerres et puis 36 le Front
populaire ça vient d'aussi loin que ça
cette épuration qu'on a vécue à la
Libération alors ça vient aussi de là je
crois que ce phénomène ou finalement la
population française va pouvoir enfin
agir massivement à la fin de
l'occupation et le croisement de
multiples motivations certaines qui
remontent effectivement au Front
populaire ou à l'entre-deux-guerres
d'autres vraiment au temps de
l'occupation on dit souvent c'est des
règlements de compte comme si c'était
une histoire de gangster non les
règlements de comptes ne sont pas là une
histoire de gangster c'est parce qu'il y
a des comptes à régler on a vu pendant
ces années là des gens bien se nourrir
alors que c'était la pénurie fréquentez
les Allemands alors qu'ils occupaient le
pays s'engager auprès des Allemands et
évidemment beaucoup de gens veulent s'en
prendre à eux à ce moment-là alors on
traque les les collabos j'ai le chiffre
d'environ bien sûr à mon avis c'est une
estimation de 10000 exécutions sommaires
attribuées à la résistance ou à des
groupes inorganisés dans les makis c'est
à peu près les chiffres qu'on retient
aujourd'hui sur cette période
précisément du début de l'épuration
dites sauvage violente
ça correspond ces chiffres correspondent
à la réalité aujourd'hui tout le monde
est à peu près d'accord sur ces chiffres
et sur les exécutions sommaires ce sont
les chiffres établis par les historiens
et vous en avez un qui a
particulièrement travaillé sur ce sujet
mais pour revenir à cette question de
l'épuration c'est moins une période
qu'un processus parce qu'en réalité
l'épuration d'abord elle est annoncée
elle est préparée elle est promise y
compris dans les textes clandestins de
l'été 40 quand on voit des jeunes filles
voilà bavarder ou liés commerce avec les
Allemands Jean Texier dans les conseils
à l'occuper de juillet 40 qui est une
feuille clandestine qui va circuler dit
bon regarde bien à quel endroit tu
pourras en gros lui donner une fessée
enfin c'est c'est un peu ce qui est dit
donc là la punition pour celle qui va
celles et ceux qui vont trahir et elle
est annoncée et le processus légal il
est mené en fait depuis Alger puisque
vous savez que l'Algérie trois
départements français sont libérés après
l'opération torche en novembre 42 et
donc le pouvoir qui va s'installer à
Alger après quelques péripéties
d'autorité de changement d'autorité va
juger et pas n'importe qui le premier à
être jugé c'est Pierre pucheux qui a été
ministre de l'Intérieur qui en se
ralliant à Giraud penser passer au camp
dit de la dissidence et qui en fait à
peine arrivé à Alger est arrêtée patient
jugement et à d'autres jugements à Alger
les tortionnaires des camps d'Afrique du
Nord la phalange africaine et évidemment
les amiraux félon enfin et donc tout le
processus si vous voulez de de
cours de justice de tribunaux militaires
fonctionnent déjà depuis Alger
pas du tout on parle de cours martial
installé dans des makis semble-t-il et
là
qui juge en réalité qui exécute en
réalité dans les makis on ne le sait pas
vraiment parce que tout ce qui a été
sommairement fait mais vous savez la
milice avant le débarquement arrive dans
la cour de la prison de la Santé
se constitue en tribunal juge et exécute
immédiatement des résistants au sein
même de la prison et donc vous voyez on
a de toute façon pour toute cette
période de l'occupation un problème
d'anomie on a on a un problème de norme
et l'été 44 correspond justement à cette
espèce de flottement qu'est-ce qu'il
était digne d'avoir comme comportement
et quand où la rumeur ou l'enquête ou en
tous les cas la voix publique dit
désigne telle ou telle femme ou
collaborationniste ou homme réputé tel
la foule
[Musique]
et de votre et de votre césure qui est
conforme à celle des documentaires c'est
à dire que la période immédiatement
consécutive à la Libération ou
accompagnant la libération aurait été
caractérisé par une épuration sauvage
cette épuration dont nous voyons le
symbole le documentaire étant très
présentant une image très pitoyable de
l'attendu de Chartres mais
peut-être que
sauvageons sauvages elle a envahi le
champ depuis une vingtaine d'années et
même 25 il n'est plus question que ça
pour d'ailleurs être opposé à ce qu'on
appelle l'épuration légale d'un état de
droit qui voudrait une épuration qui
voudrait être une rénovation de
l'appareil d'État qui voudrait oui alors
immédiate je reviens à cette libération
et à vous chiffres il faut d'abord
remarquer que de vos chiffres les deux
tiers les deux tiers de ces 10000 ont
été des exécutions dites sommets qui ont
eu lieu avant la libération et avant la
libération de Paris ce qui veut dire
qu'il reste 3000 dites exécutions
sauvages alors je voudrais rappeler
quelque chose qui a fait d'ailleurs que
j'ai intitulé mon ouvrage La
nonépuration et que je l'ai commencé par
une définition de l'épuration
ce qui s'inscrit là ce jour de
libération c'est quelque chose qui est
aussi conforme à des exécutions qui se
sont produites pas seulement parce que
les gens comme le dit le film ont
fricoté avec les Allemands ce qui est un
terme extrêmement vague mais parce que
c'est un des éléments 1943 la résistance
devient beaucoup plus forte même l'armée
devient beaucoup plus forte et
insistante à partir de 1943 où la
question ne se pose plus de savoir si
l'Allemagne sera vaincu mais quand elle
sera vaincue et à partir de là la
répression allemande est extrêmement
féroce et c'est très pression se fait
sur fond de collaboration permanente
entre des troupes allemandes les troupes
officiels françaises de la répression
des troupes cliniciennes et Associés or
ça ça n'apparaît pas du tout dans le
documentaire on n'est pas dans le
règlement de compte là on est dans
quelque chose qui est d'abord avant 1944
les combats préparatoires à la vie il y
a une épuration alors peut-être pas de
l'ampleur a
occupé le champ depuis 25 ans dans des
conditions peut-être là qui sont
absolument démentis par les sources
françaises et les sources allemandes
Fabrice Virginie moi je voulais qu'on y
voit clair sur sur un autre fait qui
semblait que selon lequel c'est là où la
était la plus forte en France où
l'épuration était elle aussi la plus
forte
c'est vérifié ça si on compare la carte
des départements français la carte des
makis français de l'époque et la carte
de l'époque le prolongement de ce que
devient de dire à la croix-rise
c'est-à-dire que sachant que les deux
tiers des personnes qui ont été
exécutées pour qu'on collaboration
exécuter n'est pas le bon terme ont été
tués c'est avant la libération une
grande partie d'entre eux sont moment
des combats qui ont lieu entre la
résistance les makis et les miliciens
ceux qui ont fait le choix de la
collaboration et donc il est
parfaitement logique que ce sont dans
les terres de Maki qui est le maximum de
victimes parmi la résistance et dans le
maquis et parmi ceux qui sont en train
de combattre que ce soit les miliciens
les groupes mobiles de réserve ou les
différentes forts de force de répression
de Vichy évidemment des Allemands une
fois que les Allemands sont partis ces
forces s'effondre et là on rentre dans
un autre processus qui est effectivement
d'attraper
ce qu'on peut ceux qui sont là parce que
une partie d'entre eux sont partis en
Allemagne
ou ont suivi l'armée allemande ou se
cache essaye de se cacher et puis on
attrape ceux qui sont là et qui est là
et bien le responsable local d'un parti
collaborationniste qui n'a pas eu le
temps de partir une femme qu'on a vu
travailler pour les Allemands ou être
traductrice auprès de la commande à
Tours ou avoir fréquenté les Allemands
uniquement les collaborateurs du
voisinage la dimension de voisinage de
l'épuration est essentielle pour
comprendre ça pourquoi ils ne sont pas à
la valve ou à péta parce qu'ils sont
déjà partis et il y a cette dimension
urgente
une aspiration vraiment populaire à s'en
prendre à ceux qui ont travaillé bon
beaucoup de délations j'imagine à
l'époque il y en a eu beaucoup aussi
sous l'Occupation dans le sens inverse
oui mais il y a une grande différence
c'est à ce moment là c'est des nations
ne sont pas
secrètes c'est à dire qu'on va chercher
les gens où on va chercher les ffiants
en leur disant mon voisin ou ma voisine
je l'ai vu elle travaillait pour les
Allemands on ne se cache pas de
prononciation parce que on considère pas
ça comme de la délation on considère ça
comme une participation à un processus
national de nettoyage de libération de
réappropriation du pays et donc on
remplit son rôle en agissant dans
l'épuration ce n'est pas d'un côté des
épurateurs et de l'autre côté une foule
qui ferait ça par hystérie par
inconscience il y a vraiment une comment
dire une rencontre entre la résistance
qui était jusque la clandestine et une
population qui veut en découdre la
tendue de chart elle a un nom c'est
Simon Touzeau et elle a un parcours
avant d'en arriver à ce fameux
1944 on regarde un deuxième extrait
fin février 1943 Simone s'inscrit au PPF
le Parti Populaire Français son
fondateur Jacques Doriot un transfuge du
Parti communiste ne cesse d'appeler à
toujours plus de collaboration avec
l'occupant et déclare où l'Europe
écrasera le bolchevisme où elle sera
détruite et bolchevisée
à plomb sur le front de l'Est n'aura que
mépris pour elle avoir 20 ans vivre à
l'époque la plus grandiose de l'histoire
humaine et faire le Zazou physiquement
et moralement
indéniablement ce discours d'inspiration
nazi fascine Simone
les adhérents du PPF sont prioritaires
pour obtenir le permis de travail en
Allemagne oui effectivement c'est une
militante d'une nationale socialiste
Simone Touzeau alors vous l'avez évoqué
un concert les profils bah oui c'était
des militants collaborationnistes des
supplétifs des Allemands des
représentants des forces de l'ordre de
Vichy ça c'est pour les hommes puis du
côté des femmes il y a la fameuse
collaboration sexuelle
collaboration dite horizontale les
employés de bureau de service les
commerçants les restauratrices les
hôtelières voilà les profils de ceux qui
étaient désignés comme collabo qui avait
probablement pour la plupart d'entre eux
réellement collaborés oui c'est très
intéressant le parcours qui est
reconstitué dans le documentaire de de
Simone parce que
ça correspond à un moment
historiographique ou finalement enfin la
lumière a été mise sur cette
collaboration des femmes dites
horizontale parce que c'est elle qu'on
tombe avec ses spectacles de rue
absolument monstrueux et en même temps
dans les travaux historiques on a
longtemps oublié la collaboration
ordinaire des femmes et ça ça a été
ressorti il y a pas très longtemps et
donc ce qui est intéressant chez Simone
c'est qu'elle va faire aussi les frais
d'une sorte de d'unité
que constitue la foule comme si la
communauté se reconstituée parce que
elle excluait et elle molestée elle
humiliait quelques éléments et
évidemment surtout féminins et puis j'en
profite pour pour dire une chose juste
avant de vous donner la parole parce que
vous avez tenu d'une comptabilité autant
qu'il est possible de le faire
concernant les femmes tondues je crois
environ 20 000 femmes et ça
représenterait 0,12% de la population
féminine de l'époque ce nombre de femmes
tondues donc on est on est quand même
sur une proportion faible très faible
même pourcentage oui
vous imaginez bien que pratiquement
impossible à compter donc c'est un ordre
de grandeur qui commence pendant
l'occupation qui va durer jusque à l'été
45 20
000 au-delà de ça ça veut dire partout
en France et je crois que c'est ça le
plus important c'est un phénomène massif
qui a lieu dans toute la France sans
excès tout les catégories sociales
toutes les catégories sociales et
auxquelles participent alors là des
centaines de milliers si ce n'est des
millions de gens qui assistent à ces
scènes là et c'est ça au-delà du nombre
c'est vraiment la dimension extrêmement
étendue d'un point de vue de la du point
de vue de la société de du phénomène le
documentaire est un extrêmement
pitoyable à la Madone qui donne lieu
évidemment à des photos très émouvantes
on perd de vue la réalité de la famille
Touzeau qui est tout à fait
significative d'une collaboration
établie c'est-à-dire qu'il ne s'agit pas
seulement d'une femme et de sa mère le
père est sans cesse présenté comme
quelqu'un qui finalement a très peur de
cette collaboration toute la famille est
impliquée les deux sœurs
quand on parle de collaboration
horizontale il est clair que la
collaboration horizontale seule si j'ose
dire n'a pas été un motif d'épuration
c'est la collaboration bien établie or
ce qu'on oublie c'est que mis à part les
prostituées qui n'ont pas été inquiétés
très peu très peu le les archives du
ministère de la justice sont très
claires là-dessus
ce qu'on reproche à ces femmes qui ont
leur métier tout simplement bien sûr qui
ont vécu qui ont vécu avec des Allemands
c'est évidemment de ne pas borner leur
leur participation à des rapports
sexuels c'est-à-dire qu'elles ont
dénoncé je donne un exemple d'ailleurs
qui qui est cité dans le livre de
Monsieur
Fabrice Virginie dans ces femmes tondues
un moment il parle d'une femme qui a été
lynchée par la par la foule ces jeunes
de Vinot Jeanne Devineau on a une
instruction extrêmement claire
et quelqu'un qui a été utilisé par ce
qu'on appelle la Gestapo de Marseille et
qui a ravagé la région qui est notamment
poursuivi pour avoir conduit les
colonnes allemandes à une vingtaine de
maquisards qu'elle a fait arrêter 17 ont
été tués entre ceux qui ont été tués
dans l'immédiat et ceux qui ont été des
portes déportés mais là c'est vraiment
toute la force de l'image et du
clichés des milliers d'autres
semblent nous dire voilà ces jeunes
femmes ont été punies parce qu'elles ont
couché avec les Allemands et quand on va
voir les dossiers parce qu'il y a des
dossiers non pas de tonte mais de
dossiers de femmes tondu qui passe
devant les commissions d'épurations on
voit bien que ce n'est pas pour ça
une chose essentielle elles sont tondues
en plus elle collabore comme les hommes
mais ils ont une sanction supplémentaire
on peut être tondu et fusillés on peut
être tendu et emprisonné
elles sont aussi exécutées je crois que
certaines environ de ces femmes non non
beaucoup moins d'accord
on a parlé de l'épuration immédiate je
l'ai appelé sauvage vous m'avez expliqué
que les choses n'étaient pas tout à fait
à diviser de cette manière là on va
parler si vous permettez maintenant
d'une épuration qu'on pourrait peut-être
qualifier de légal cette fois c'est donc
c'est ce qui nous est dit dans le
documentaire c'est le début des grands
procès
de Gaulle et son gouvernement provisoire
ont rétabli les pouvoirs publics dans
leur fonction et mis fin au règlement de
comptes sauvages
l'heure de l'épuration légale a sonné
les cours de justice tournent à plein
régime
c'est la saison des grands procès
celui de Pétain de Laval de Bonnie et de
la font escronautoir et redoutable
supplétif de la Gestapo l'épuration dite
légale ont peut-être en débat mais enfin
j'espère pas trop non plus
il y a quelques chiffres par exemple on
a vu Laval Pétain ça c'est les
évidemment la Haute Cour de justice qui
a été mise en place pour pour juger
notamment les hauts fonctionnaires là là
on a des chiffres très très précis 108
personnalités jugées donc un chef d'État
est un président du Conseil Laval 106
mini secrétaire d'État est très haut
fonctionnaires et le tout entre mars
1945 et janvier 1946 là on parle de
l'épuration au sein de l'appareil d'État
est-ce qu'on peut dire que l'épuration
au sein de l'appareil d'État a été
conséquente en attente avec ce qui était
l'attente justement peut-être de la
population à l'époque un choix que les
puration dites légales et surtout de ces
de ces stars de ces dignitaires on va
dire de Vichy elle a à la fois focalisé
la presse du monde entier qui assiste au
procès Pétain au procès Laval et en même
temps ça a laissé tout le monde un peu
insatisfait d'abord parce que les
premiers qui sont qui passent en
jugement sont les journalistes et hommes
de l'être des l'automne 44
certains sont évidemment fusillés tout
de suite et un débat est lancé tout de
suite alors pourquoi doit-on fusiller
les écrivains alors qu'on n'a pas encore
jugé ni le régime de Vichy ni les
dignitaires donc il y a un problème de
chronologie en tous les cas l'opinion ne
comprend pas pourquoi on fusil d'abord
brasiliaque alors que Pétain et Laval ne
sont pas encore passé en jugement et
l'autre chose qui est
insatisfaisante c'est finalement mais
plus le temps passe et plus on voit que
les les en tous les cas le public pense
que les les verdicts sont moins sévères
et donc certains avocats avec assez de
finesse d'ailleurs font traîner les
procédures sachant que quand on est jugé
en 47 si on n'est pas un très grand
dignitaire de Vichy on a plus de chance
d'avoir une peine de travaux forcés de
Simone Touzeau
qui est une stratégie bien connue alors
la non-épuration alors là j'en reviens à
votre livre alors est-ce que voilà la
nonaturation cette fois sur cette
période
dites légales là pour vous le contenu
n'est pas comme vous l'avez alors vous
l'avez répondu
peut-être du volume que ça représente il
y a 400 000 dossiers
jugés dans les tribunaux avec moins de
800 exécutions à la peine de mort au
final voilà ça sont les chiffres qui
donnent une bonne idée de l'ensemble et
ça ça vous paraît pas du tout suffisant
par rapport à ce qui était lenteur de la
collaboration en France il faut revenir
à la chronologie que vous avez ce qui
c'est quand vous avez parlé de du rôle
d'Alger alors je rappelle quand même que
finalement l'épuration légale et veut
dire elle se définit d'abord à Alger
elle se définit d'abord avant Alger
parce que les Américains eux-mêmes en
donnent les linéaments avec les
directives du 22 septembre 1942 de
Roosevelt et les directives de Roosevelt
sont très claires
rien ne change aucun changement
c'est-à-dire on ne touche pas à
l'appareil civile on a tous pas à
l'appareil militaire
alors vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
les protestations ça a été dit en
particulier évidemment les vigies
radiophoniques de Radio Londres et
d'Alger promettant à la population parce
qu'on a évoqué la volonté de la
population mais il faut évoquer les
promesses de Londres et d'Alger d'une
épuration exemplaire contre ceux en
particulier qui exécutaient les
patriotes et je pense en particulier aux
agents de répression de la police et de
la gendarmerie et aux agents d'exécution
judiciaire qui ont liés à la mort dans
votre livre au final vous faites vous le
constat que si je peux m'exprimer comme
ça le compte n'y est pas par rapport à
ce qui était spécial
de De Gaulle ce qui est intéressant dans
la chronologie c'est c'est de montrer
l'effet et de Gaulle n'est pas un
épurateur ça commence par je dirais son
cabinet
souvent l'exemple de son premier
ministre des Finances qui passe pour un
goûtiste féminent qui écoute de Murville
qui a été le deuxième personnage du
ministère des Finances de Vichy auprès
du par lequel sont passés toutes les
opérations financières franco-allemande
y compris les grandes opérations à
réalisation session de titres sociétés
mix etc il ne veut pas l'épuration et il
subit la pression très forte des
Américains et des Anglais auxquels fin
43 début 44 à Alger il donne des
engagements qui montrent que le procès
qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure de
pucheux sera finalement un procès unique
et qui n'est pas dû d'ailleurs comme on
l'a dit à la pression du Parti
communiste qui est due à la volonté de
De Gaulle de prévenir les Américains que
n'acceptera pas le gouvernement
militaire
Fabrice Virginie est-ce que de Gaulle ne
voulait pas de suppuration ou alors lui
et son gouvernement provisant ont-ils
essayé de canaliser cette cette
épuration parce qu'il s'agit de
reconstruire le pays aussi à cette
période comment est-ce qu'on peut
évaluer les choses l'épuration et donc
la justice qui se fait du point de vue
légal au nom de l'article 75 du code
pénal qui prévoit de punir la trahison
en temps de guerre fait partie des
prérogatives de l'État et de ce point de
vue là de Gaulle veut incarner et
assurer que cette prorative soit bien
assumée également vis-à-vis des
Américains puisqu'il s'agit de restaurer
l'état ensuite il y a un autre élément
qui est
bien entendu la crainte qu'il peut avoir
et le combat politique qu'il mène même
s'ils sont alliés au sein de la des FFI
et puis du gouvernement de la France
libre vis-à-vis des communistes et la
crainte qu'il a effectivement et c'est
vrai que cette crainte est partagée par
un certain nombre de personnes qui est
une tentative de prise du pouvoir à
terme par partie communiste et donc il
est aussi entre les deux mais c'est
clair que l'épuration se déroule sous
son gouvernement
plus chaud et condamné à moralger et
c'est un signe très important vis-à-vis
de Vichy parce qu'il y a une manière de
leur dire vous ne pourrez pas tourner de
vos vestes vous serez puni il y a
d'autres condamnations à mort on les a
vu pourquoi est-ce qu'on commence par
les journalistes avant de s'en prendre à
Laval et à Pékin parce qu'à ce moment-là
la vallée pétains sont encore en
Allemagne en octobre 44 ils sont assez
maringen et pourtant il y a une demande
le temps de mettre en place les cours de
justice de faire les dossiers parce que
on se dit toujours ah oui de trouver les
juges
parce qu'ils avaient tous faits serment
ce sont des dossiers vides mais il y a
des enquêtes c'est-à-dire que non quand
on travaille on le sait tous quand on
travaille sur ces dossiers ces archives
ce sont pas des dossiers vite sont des
dossiers où il y a dans un temps certes
beaucoup plus bref qu'entente paix mais
on est quand même en 44 45 on va
chercher des preuves on va alimenter
pour que ces procédés et donc c'est tous
processus alors ensuite c'est vrai alia
on disait justement tout à l'heure c'est
plus un processus qu'un moment les plus
rations et donc ce processus a des
rythmes différents effectivement et
petit à petit la sévérité une fois
assurée la non prise du pouvoir par la
partie communiste et le rétablissement
des autorités républicaines il y a
tendance justement à ce moment là à
beaucoup plus d'indulgence et beaucoup
plus de grâce de Gaulle un rôle
important dans les grasses
vous dites les rythmes différents
est-ce que vous avez en tête quelques
comparaisons il semblerait que la
libération était très forte aussi par
exemple en Belgique en Norvège au
Pays-Bas au Danemark autrement assez
semblable à ce qui s'est passé en France
là je parle de l'Europe de l'Ouest bien
sûr il y a des historiens qui ont
comparé par exemple le taux de
condamnation effective et exécuter par
rapport
aux chiffres de la population et la
France n'arrive pas du tout en tête dans
ces dans ces classements on est plutôt
parmi finalement les derniers ça vous
donnerait
les pays les moins épurateurs là où ça a
été très
dense comme épuration c'est en Belgique
et même au Danemark en Hollande aussi
donc dans des pays qui étaient
finalement sous un une autre forme
d'occupation que que la France le
Danemark était quasi annexé et a été à
la fois préservé puisque le gouvernement
danoises quand même des élections au
Danemark pendant la guerre mais avec une
très forte résistance des juifs qui ont
été sauvés mais aussi un très fort de
collaboration individuelle
moi je récuse en particulier la
chronologie
de la sévérité ou de l'indulgence parce
que le maintien total de l'appareil
d'État et en particulier de l'appareil
judiciaire qui est d'ailleurs établi
formellement grâce à un annuaire de la
magistrature puisqu'on peut suivre
toutes les carrières de tous les
magistrats tout ceci attestent avec les
textes des magistrats des magistrats et
la littérature du ministère de la
Justice de la chancellerie de l'appareil
directe directeur que en réalité il n'y
a pas cette évolution et que il y a
indulgence extrêmement forte
on n'a pas eu le temps de parler et de
des catégories d'épurations de
l'épuration économique de l'épuration
politique etc mais on voit bien que le
discours de 1944 de la part des hauts
magistrats est un discours qui ne se
distingue guère de la période où les
hauts magistrats considéraient les FTPF
comme des voyous et des assassins qui
n'étaient pas des résistants mais des
gangsters vous avez 20 secondes mais je
vous laisse je crois qu'on peut pas dire
qu'il y a maintien de l'appareil d'État
parce que l'épuration touche également
l'appareil d'État il y a une invention
juridique la Cour de justice c'est
certes de prendre un juge parce que
c'est un professionnel de la justice qui
a pu servir sous Vichy mais de Louis
adjointe comme à ses soeur des
résistants d'une part et donc voilà si
on regarde à l'échelle de des 10 ans non
pas à l'échelle des quelques mois il y a
comme un renouvellement générationnel de
l'appareil d'État et des élites alors il
y a aussi en même temps c'est pour ça
que moi je parlerai plus à un moment de
désépuration ou de contriburation on va
juger les résistants à la fin des années
50 exactement et au contraire suspendre
les condamnations graciées communées
réintégrer dans l'administration un
certain nombre de personnes qui avaient
été
pour collaboration mais ça ne veut pas
dire qu'elles ne l'ont pas été sauf que
effectivement à la fin des années 40
début des années 50 il y a une sorte de
retour en arbre pas de retour en arrière
mais de comment dire on change le
curseur autour de mon retournement merci
beaucoup Fabrice Virginie merci vraiment
à tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat d'ocre aujourd'hui à cette période
trouble notre histoire que fut les plus
rations pendant et après la Libération
vous pouvez réagir à cette émission sur
hashtag des Badoc c'est notre nouvelle
adresse sur Twitter je vous engage et
vous je vous le demande si vous en êtes
d'accord de réagir vous aussi puisque
c'est une manière de continuer à faire
vivre ce qui vient de le dire dans cette
émission à tous et à toutes pour un
prochain débat doc avec bien sûr son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]